and now we'll move on to this great
moment this call out where Ben is
printing something in this scene if you
have eagle eyes with quick pausing
skills you'll see that Ben is using a
saber printer the same saber from the
office in fact some research has told me
that saber printers have been spotted on
Dexter as well wow I don't know I think
that's a cool little is it that's what
they call an Easter egg is that that
kind of yeah it's probably an Easter egg
it could be a thing where this was then
created for the office and then they
have a lot of props in their prop houses
does that make sense and so our you know
our prop people Gabriella is probably
like oh we should bring in the saber
right
um Sabre as they first thought the uh
right the company was called anyway well
I'm a huge you know a huge office fan
and so I love those kind of yeah little
things I just love it so Ron taking it
upon himself to fix things in April
Andy's house right first he goes to
Lowe's
and he refuses to help or the guy comes
up and says sir can I help you and says
I know more than you to the sales
associates and the sales house is like
okay yeah great I don't have to deal
with you wonderful it's the perfect
scenario for them but I'm gonna have to
call out the writers on this one and say
did I swear on this podcast oh dare you
to I'm gonna say here's why you
say have you ever gone to Home
Depot or Lowe's yes no one looks at you
yeah they do not help you yeah so for
the show it was perfect because that's
the perfect round answer it's so perfect
I know more than you do yes get away
from me but they never help you it's
true I am the living example of that
because I go in I know nothing I can
repair nothing so when I go to YouTube
and like oh I think I can do that then
my God how simple a could do that
and then as a I go there and I
can't figure any of it out and I ask for
help and they're no one no one to be
found I've had the moment I I was like I
once I needed I need to get nails I was
close to the Home Depot I'm like I'm
gonna go get some nails and I go in that
aisle and I didn't realize what nails
were until I was like I thought you just
bought a box of nails like you bought a
box of paper clips right you would think
anyway the story of Ron fixing things in
the house it kind of reminds me of an
episode of The Office speaking of that
show it's season three episode 18 it's
cocktails and it's when they go to the
party at David Wallace's house and
Dwight winds up it's this weird sea
story with him where he just gives it a
very thorough inspection yeah it is
interesting there's something really
similar I would guess a bit about Dwight
and Ron in this storyline which is that
I'm in this place I have this interest
in this thing and I'm not going to let
that stop me like I'm not gonna go to
the party I'm not just gonna be a party
I'm Gonna Be Myself and I just can't
help it but as a gift for them as this
housewarming gift for them I'm gonna fix
their house and what goes against all
social norms yes you don't show up to
someone's house and start looking for
problems right unless you're like my
family who whenever they come to my
house they're like do you notice that
the the toilet's like a little like the
things a little loose my dad will do
this thing where he'll just
take any poster that's not level he'll
just level it like he has perfect level
Vision but also like don't touch my
stuff right it's all it's my house maybe
I don't want it like that anyway
um we'll save that for my therapy
session